brooklyn nine-nine finally
coming to its
eighth season like this season has been
in the making for like
almost two years like almost two years
and
it's got so many things have happened in
the world um our writers have had to
rewrite this
season
at least three times
um based on just covet and black lives
matter and all that
and then george floyd and then some
other stuff happened with and so
it was just an endless that's their
their commitment to getting it right and
making it funny is just so impressive to
me
um i would i get back to patients i
wouldn't have the patience for it i'm
like oh enough just nbc just take these
we did this a year ago well they love
the show that much that they rewrote the
entire season
they really did how many episodes uh we
did 10 episodes and you're done
this is it unfortunately until you know
whatever reunion happens which i'm sure
it will at some point but how emotional
is that for you on your last day of
shooting
very vividly yeah very vividly it was uh
you know all day is filled you you get
to the lot and all day it's just filled
with anticipation everyone knows
that it's gonna end today and so all the
scenes that you're doing
there's kind of like you're trying to be
present but it's really about like soon
the final scene's coming up the final
scene is coming up the final thing it's
going to come up and so
you know it was uh truly great to have
everyone there and uh
and and feel that out and then then that
scene comes
and uh
you know i can't give uh any of it away
but i'll say that
it was very difficult to uh for the eyes
not to stay wet during the scene because
the scene is uh is very close to what
was happening in real life
and um
and there was just this palpable like
pulsating in the room
um so during the shot there's like this
moment during the scene there's this
moment and
we're all making eye contact and it's
truly
oh i get emotional thinking about it was
so intense and and then it ends and um
you know the where it really sank in is
like before the take started our um
um
uh one of our uh
crew members i could also tell you like
like the emotion on you that you're just
i could see you oh
you're you're going back i'm going back
in and trying to resist